bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin sur rtl france
pour débattre de cette question faut-il
partir du mali interrogé hier sur un
éventuel retrait de la force barkan
voyez la réponse du chef du quai d'orsay
hier
si les conditions ne sont plus réunies
ce qui est manifestement le cas pour
qu'on puisse être en mesure d'agir au
mali on continuera à combattre le
terrorisme à côté avec les pays du sahel
qui sont tout à fait demandeur c'est la
junte qui s'isole qui perd et qui devra
assumer la suite votre réaction pierre
laurent à cet éventuel retrait du mali
vous savez ça fait des mois que je dis
que et même des années que je dis que
l'opération barkan est dans une impasse
parce que au départ
les autorités maliennes nous ont demandé
une intervention qui était d'ailleurs
une intervention aérienne c'était ce qui
était demandé contre des colonnes de
djihadistes qui descendait de la libye
vers le centre du mali nous avons choisi
de faire une intervention massive et au
lieu d'apporter la sécurité promise elle
a généré la générali une généralisation
de la violence dans le mali est
maintenant dans les pays du sahel n'a
pas endigué la violence et elle a coûté
cher en vies humaines deux soldats
français mais il faut le dire aussi de
centaines et de centaines de soldats des
armées locales maliennes et nigériennes
et des pays
d autres pays voisins donc cette
opération est dans une impasse je pense
qu'il faut un agenda de retrait de nos
troupes et surtout il faut substituer à
cet agenda de militaires un agenda de
coopération et de développement donc il
faut comme le disait un gros
intervenants s'asseoir à la table de
négociation avec les les autorités
maliennes et les pays du sahel pour
discuter d'une autre manière d'aider ces
pays à construire leur développement
alors le mal avec la vallée c'est
compliqué de discuter en ce moment que
de gagner vous êtes d'accord avec ça il
faut on est dans une impasse au mali
dans wii avec on ne peut pas rester au
mali bien évidemment ne sommes pas une
force d'occupation sommes pas devant
quitter le mali bien sûr vont pas le
quitter brutalement de l'opération
barkan ti comme là ça a été rappelée
s'inscrit dans la lignée de cerval a
obtenu de très bons résultats on a
encore récemment vu des résultats
contre des djihadistes qui et qui ont
démontré que notre capacité à lutter
contre le terrorisme était réelle
maintenant les la force la junte au
pouvoir au mali ne veut plus de nous
donc on a on ne peut pas rester bien
évidemment mais il convient qu'on reste
dans cette région il est impératif que
la france qui a démontré sa capacité
largement c'est capacité à lutter contre
le terrorisme quelles que puissent
rester maintenant il convient
effectivement et nous attendons les
déclarations du président la république
française sur la façon dont on peut se
redéployer localement sur les pays
voisins qui souhaite qu'on garde une
stabilité dans cette région de la bande
sahélo saharienne
mais on va en parler plus en détails en
tout cas un retrait qui devrait être
annoncée mercredi au jeudi lors de ce
fameux sommet entre l'union européenne
et l'union africaine est ce que c'est ce
retrait n'est pas néanmoins un revers on
est évidemment en campagne électorale
actuellement pierre laurent est ce que
ce sera un revers pour emmanuel macron
d'annoncer son retrait
c'est certain que emmanuel macron et
tous ceux qui ont soutenu cette
intervention militaire parce que nous
avons je me rappelle débattu au
parlement il ya très peu de temps à
notre demande en tout cas au sénat sur
cette question il y avait encore
beaucoup de parlementaires français pour
soutenir cette intervention alors
qu'elle était déjà dans l'impasse donc
bien sûr que c'est un échec
d'un certain type de relations avec
l'afrique on aurait dû s'arrêter à
serval selon vous
je crois qu'après serval il fallait
donner la priorité
après l'acompte la construction de
solutions politiques pour le mali de
solutions économiques pour le mali et
c'est ce que nous n'avons pas fait au
contraire nous nous sommes enfoncés dans
une logique militaire qui dès le départ
ne pouvait conduire à la solution de la
situation d'ailleurs je me rappelle que
le chef d'état major des armées à
l'époque
sur lecointe quand il intervenait devant
la commission de défense au sénat
rappeler sans cesse que la solution ne
serait pas militaire mais qu'elle serait
politique et cette solution politique
nous ne l'avons pas exploré comme il
fallait et nous sommes aujourd'hui
devant la même question donc on peut
toujours dire qu'on va rester au sahel
avec des militaires mais là le fond du
problème c'est de construire une logique
de développement maîtrisé par les
africains et c'est cette logique là que
nous voulons toujours pas emprunter et
qui est pourtant la seule solution à la
stabilisation de la région un club de
ganay 7 ce sont des militaires français
qui sont engagés dans berkane mais
également cette force takouba qui est
une force européenne
est ce que est ce que c'est pas non plus
la halle à l'échec en tout cas de cet
embryon de défense européenne alors donc
et il ya déjà bien sûr la minus
maquiller sur place avec une force une
hygiène avec près de 12 mille hommes il
ya aussi cette force takouba qui a été
mise en place progressivement avec
l'arrivée de plusieurs militaires de
européens qui ont le reconnaître un peu
tardé qui ne veulent mondiale est
aujourd'hui quasiment on est d'accord
donc baissé de force takouba il faut
aussi donc en discuter comment elle va
se débat seraient tirées s'arrêter de
ceux de quitter somalie je pense qu'il
va avoir un débat donc nous au parlement
à l'assemblée nationale la semaine
prochaine au 22 février pour discuter
seulement de ce que tout le contour de
ce redéploiement bon et ça va intervenir
juste après lecture j'ai les questions
au gouvernement donc ça démontre quand
même qu'hier il ya un enjeu important et
qu'il est que le parlement doit être
donc associés on ne peut pas il faut
absolument qu'on reste quand même dans
la région pour maintenir 7,7 l'oeuvre
qu'on a engagés on a effectivement fait
est rappelé en a perdu des militaires
moi je nous armer on a perdu 58 hommes
dont une femme et qui sont pas bas et ce
centre ils sont pas morts pour rien on a
ils ont eu des succès et on a combattu
et encore récemment
décimé encore une certain nombre de deux
dj annie et donc et dont la tête de sur
place donc un des chefs de
l'état et famille qu'est ça serait
dramatique que se reconstituent un
sanctuaire islamistes là bas qui
viendraient
depuis là-bas de présenter des dvd et
attend que chez nous c'est un risque
réel est ce que c'est le même type en
tout cas de menace pierre laurent cette
ce terrorisme djihadisme africain et il
est une réelle menace pour la france
je crois que c'est d'abord une menace
pour les africains
il rappelle d'ailleurs que nous portons
une responsabilité dans la situation
déstabilisation de la région
puisque notre intervention militaire en
libye à l'époque a généré la diffusion
aujourd'hui dans tout le sahel de
groupes djihadistes surarmés et qui
répondent la terreur donc le problème de
sécurité il est d'abord un problème pour
pour les africains et si aujourd'hui les
africains et les maliens estime que ce
n'est pas de cette manière que nous
allons assurer la sécurité et le bilan
de 10 ans de barkan le montrent eh bien
il faut discuter avec eux vous disiez
tout à l'heure après mon intervention
qu'on pouvait pas discuter avec les
autorités maliennes c'était difficile et
pourtant il faut discuter avec tous les
pays de la région il n'y aura pas de
solutions qui ne soient pas discuter
avec les pays de la région aujourd'hui
nous soutenons un blocus du mali qui a
été décidée par la cedeao mais sous
pression notamment de la france c'est
une impasse totale les maliens vivent
les maliens qui vivent en france sont
extrêmement inquiets de cette situation
parce que évidemment ceux qui souffrent
du blocus actuel ce n'est pas les les
dirigeants malir actuelle c'est d'abord
le temps le malien donc il faut en toute
circonstance dans ces affaires ton c'est
aux peuples africains c'est eux d'abord
qui sont au premier rang des difficultés
c'est peut-être là où emmanuel macron
n'a pas forcément pris suffisamment la
température de l'opinion publique
africaine jours et qu'on écoute le
premier ministre malien justement qui a
qualifié les forces barkan de
mercenaires il a d'ailleurs fait un
parallèle avec l'afghanistan regardez
nous avons le sentiment que la présence
massive des forces étrangères et la
multiplication des opérations militaires
sont inversement proportionnels à
l'expansion du terrorisme en afghanistan
la lassitude et l'impuissance de la
communauté internationale après vingt
ans de présence militaire ont fini par
mettre les afghans devant leur triste
sort donc l'hôte de gan est finalement
là les forces français sont perçus comme
des forces d'occupation à après neuf ans
de présence au mali est ce que ça se
comprend alors écoutez le sens le
gouvernement malmat malien actuellement
la junte ne fait que que provoquer
avec des ddd terme qui sont absurdes de
lits ils sont aujourd'hui il ya pas
clair il ya tous les mercenaires de
wagner qui sont sur l'option sur le
terrain au mali et on va comparer les
soldats français à des mercenaires bon
écoute et on verra je peux vous dire que
le peuple malien qui est manipulé et se
retrouvent et comprendra très vite quand
on verra les exactions commises par les
mercenaires de wagner alors que la
france quant à arriver dans nos bambins
claude degano manipuler parti le peuple
malien mais pas comme par le
gouvernement la junte militaire en place
trouve son intérêt
à attaquer la france à faire une
communication scandaleuse quoi vous êtes
d'accord récemment avec ce 4e et quand
ils ont ils ont récemment
dénoncé à une violation de l'espace
aérien par un avion militaire français
l'a400m qui était pourtant qu'à des
missions logistiques entre abidjan et la
base de gao il y en a eu et il y en a
régulièrement donc ils n'arrêtent pas de
dust2 de susciter des convocations ce
type le loup pierre leroy que pensez
vous de cette déclaration du premier
ministre malien
la déclaration que vous venez de lire
elle fait un constat qui est
malheureusement
la réalité c'est à dire que si nous
continuons à rester dans ces conditions
tout ça va se terminer comme
l'afghanistan est évidemment pas plus
que le peuple afghan ne tire profit de
la situation actuelle le peuple malien
dont il rappe profite
évidemment moi je suis contre la
militarisation la région la
militarisation à outrance donc je ne
suis pas pour substituer aux soldats
français les milices wagner une milice
privée russe qui est extrêmement
inquiétante danser dans ses pratiques je
suis pour au contraire on trouve le
moyen de retrouver les voies de la
sécurité et de la paix ce qui passe par
le fait de conforter ses états et non
pas de les isoler ou de les soumettre à
des à des blocus il faut trouver une
autre voie de dialogue qui soit centré
sur la question du du développement de
ces pays parce que on oublie que les
groupes djihadistes qui progresse dans
la région le fonds en s'appuyant sur les
failles des états sur le fait que ces
états sont maintenues dans un état de
pauvreté absolue et tout ça est
extrêmement inquiétant y compris pour
nous qui avons de longue tradition de
rapports avec l'afrique
donc je crois qu'il faut si nous voulons
construire des voies de sécurité c'est
qu'une sécurité globale qui s'attaquera
aux problèmes de la pauvreté au problème
du manque de développement au problème
de la maîtrise des ressources par les
africains cc voilà qu'il faut explorer
et que nous continuons de ne pas
explorer alors on va écouter justement
les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle qui ont qui se sont
exprimés sur cette situation et ce
retrait éventuel de la france regardez
la france a perdu une influence folle en
afrique nous n'avons pas vocation à
rester dans un pays qui ne veut pas de
nous nos soldats meurent pour un pays
qui nous humilie tout cela finit dans un
imbroglio qui n'est pas digne claude de
gagner on l'a dit il ya près de
cinquante soldats français qui sont
morts dans cet dans cette guerre oksana
l 58 précisément au total je parlais du
mali précisément mais 58 au total est ce
que finalement ce sera l'enjeu pour le
prochain président de la république de
se sortir de deux de ceux de cet
imbroglio et comment non mais oh là là
où je rejoins mon collègue l'équipe hôte
maintenir un dialogue avec l'ensemble
des pays africains localement et puis
également bien sûr travailler sur le
développement sur la formation et
permettre à ces pays at-elle de ceux de
se développer
par effectivement les aides économiques
bien ciblés mais au cas aujourd'hui le
mali pose vraiment proposera pas moins
un problème dans la dans cette
négociation future avec les le futur
président de la république ou la future
présidente de la république ce qui a eu
des erreurs de commises en termes de
politique étrangère emmanuel macron s'en
souvient avait convoqué à pau les
dirigeants du g5 scène c'était une
convocation pas une invitation ça a été
mal perçue par les dirigeants de ces
cinq pays impliqués dans dans cette
lutte contre le terrorisme au sahel
pierre laurent pardon oui
écoutez on voit bien que en fait on a
depuis des années on nous a présenté à
chaque fois que je me rappelle jean yves
le drian ou ou florence parle il venait
devant la commission une situation de
rapports idyllique avec les pays du g5
sahel où nous a fait le même récit sur
nos rapports avec les pays européens
pour la force nakba on devrait bien tout
ça n'était pas la réalité
aujourd'hui il y a dans les opinions
publiques africaines et très au delà du
mali une demande d'un autre type de
rapport avec la france je rappelle que
le problème de ce que se passe au loup
avec le mali
quand un convoi militaire français à
traverser il ya quelques mois
le sud de la région en traversant le
burkina faso pour se rendre au niger il
ya eu des incidents extrêmement graves
avec des morts avec des manifestations
contre ce convoi militaire donc il y à
une demande qui monte dans l'afrique
devoir
d'exiger que les voies du développement
soit maintenant maîtrisé par les
africains et nous devons coopérer parce
que nous avons intérêt ou développement
de l'afrique et nous n'avons pas intérêt
à traiter l'afrique comme seulement une
zone d'influencé de la france mais comme
une région qui doit se développer par
elle-même ce n'est pas la même chose et
il nous reste très peu de temps que
l'hôte de gagner vous l'avez dire il y
aura un débat au parlement
la semaine prochaine
enfin un débat si je puis dire ça a été
réclamée de longue date par les députés
oui ça fait vrai de jeu nous l'avons
réclamé à plusieurs reprises pour qu'on
ait cet échange avec le gouvernement sur
ce problème très important
donc moi je considère qu'on a on a le
temps on est partis pour lutter contre
le terrorisme on a réussi maintenant
nous sommes chassés du mali est pas du
tout vent quitter le mali mais il
restait dans la région est effectivement
réfléchir à une aide à d'autres voient
maintenant de développement comme on
gagne des camps bien le dire en
collègues merci beaucoup à tous les deux
on en reparlera évidemment un merci
d'avoir des battues dans la matinale
alerté france ce matin